moi j'ai un double regard le regard de
l'opinion publique ça ne pourra pas
cette disparition ne pas créer une
énorme émotion parce que du fait de sa
longévité pour nos jeudis avait rappelé
un 63 ans de carrière politique non de
carrière journalistique c'est une
famille qui s'est installée avec les
Français d'ailleurs c'est un des rats
journalistes qui a un moment à figurer
dans le top 50 des personnalités
préférées on préfère toujours la
longévité le fait de créer une relation
familière avec un acteur
un homme politique ou un journaliste à
l'instantanéité des influenceurs des
youtubeurs ou des réseaux sociaux et
donc des moments de télévision que
personne n'oubliera les échanges avec
Georges Marchais les dernières
interviews avec François Mitterrand en
94 95 ou c'était absolument émouvant et
puis en même temps une sorte de une
sorte de maïeutique pour faire parler
François Mitterrand à l'aube à l'aube de
enfin à l'aube dans les dernières années
de sa vie et du point de vue de la
relation que j'ai pu avoir avec lui
c'est une véritable passion les sondages
ça le passionnait Michael vous parliez
d'innovation quand unifop a pour Europe
1 et Paris Match introduit le Rolling
des enquêtes électorales quotidiennes
mais il m'appelait quasiment tous les
jours pour avoir les choses un peu avant
il trop il était très féru d'innovation
et effectivement il y a cette passion
qui fait que il nous embarquait dans sa
ville journaliste avec effectivement de
multiples appels et il fallait il
fallait prendre au téléphone parce que
sinon ça devenait deux trois quatre cinq
appels il fallait absolument mais il ne
nous lâchez pas et puis l'idée je reçois
x demain qu'est-ce que tu lui dirais
qu'est-ce que tu lui poserais l'idée qui
se nourrissait toute une série
d'influence différentes et c'est vrai
que de ce point de vue là il est unique
et c'est ce qui explique à mon avis
l'émotion et le fait que de multiples
journalistes mais c'est vrai que c'est
sa transmission il a réussi à
transmettre la passion du métier tout le
monde durant mage ouais David insuline
vous l'avez côtoyer notamment ici quand
il des PDG de Public Sénat jusqu'en 2009
qu'est-ce qui vous a marqué chez
Jean-Pierre Elkabbach
quand je suis arrivé je n'avais aucune
proximité d'ailleurs j'ai jamais une
intimité avec lui mais je le regardais
comme quand j'étais ado et je le
regardais déjà à la télé et ce qui me
frappait c'était son côté
aussi éternel adolescent moqueur curieux
et puis je me souviens de mes premières
questions d'actualité
j'étais un peu dans l'émotion et j'avais
pas compris à l'époque que quand il y
avait le droit toute la droite était en
train de j'étais un peu dur avec Sarkozy
d'ailleurs dans l'hémicycle me couvrait
et donc je parlais au-dessus je priais
un peu dans le micro et je me souviens
il était venu me dire en sortant il faut
il faut rester calme jamais monté comme
ça parce qu'on vous entend pas à la télé
on attend les cris mais on n'entend pas
le droit bon ça je l'ai retenu et vous
avez transmis ensuite mais donc une
bienveillance voilà il avait quand même
interviewé moi voilà j'étais comme un
spectateur devant ma télé depuis mon
adolescence les
acteurs de la vie politique nationale et
internationale
majeur et j'étais frappé par le fait
qu'il avait toujours
un regard bienveillant pour pour le 9
pour le nouveau et donc y compris les
jeunes qui arrivaient en politique et on
avait des poils l'impression qui
voulaient presque être conseiller
pas seulement journaliste et moi j'ai
été interviewé par lui Europe 1 le
fameux gras des hommes politiques et
c'était comment alors comment on se
prépare une interview faciale c'est un
peu agaçant
c'est un peu agaçant parce que il avait
une faculté de constamment interrompre
moi qui ai besoin de démonstration tout
ça bon
ça m'agace un peu mais en même temps il
savait où il allait c'est-à-dire il se
il y avait quelques minutes d'interviews
c'est très court et il fallait sortir
des choses et donc il maîtriser il
maîtrisait dans un dans une espèce de
match ou il était quand même on sentait
que ça l'amusait à la fin je me disais
si la scène politique était une scène de
théâtre il était un acteur un peu qui
regardait tout ça avec même s'il était
très
impliqué dans les passions du monde et
dans dans les enjeux d'être parfois
dramatiques j'avais l'impression que il
regardait ça comme vieil acteur ou comme
un vieil star
et c'est vrai qu'il avait un rôle
effectivement c'était presque un jeu
l'interview politique avec avec
Jean-Pierre Elkabbach presque aussi
important que le politique et pourtant
Jean-Pierre Le notamment quand il est
ici à publique Sénat j'imagine que
c'était pareil à Europe 1 Michael Darmon
il nous disait toujours de que c'était
l'invité qu'on avait envie d'entendre et
pas et pas le journaliste et pourtant
Jean-Pierre Elkabbach il restera il
restera aussi marquant que les invités
qu'il a reçu oui parce que il d'abord il
disait je suis un passeur et moi je dans
les conversation quotidiennes qu'on
avait puisqu'on était vraiment avec lui
c'était une conversation permanente et
et rappeler sans arrêt que le au fond le
métier de journaliste c'est un choix
d'existence ça se termine pas à 18h ça
se termine pas à une heure précise pas
de week-end pas de vacances on est on
est journaliste parce qu'on vit le
journalisme et ça c'était quelque chose
qui effectivement a beaucoup beaucoup
raisonné en moi il effectivement il
avait aussi cette espèce de distance un
peu le saltimbanque moi quand j'ai
commencé ma carrière dans dans des
chaînes comme comme TF1 ou à France 2
j'avais effectivement des il y avait des
gens comme lui qui disaient mais il faut
pas oublier que nous sommes que des
journalistes
et de ce point de vue là il y avait à la
fois une grande implication et une
distance vous savez ce proverbe qui dit
le journaliste menait de menatou à
condition de le quitter lui ou avec lui
c'était le joyeuse Manato à condition
d'y rester parce que ça permettait de
pouvoir aborder tous les sujets et parce
qu'on est sur hommage au journaliste
national mais il a peut-être le seul
dans notre métier en France à avoir
interviewé tous les dirigeants de la
planète depuis donc la deuxième partie
du deuxième du 20e siècle le début de ce
millénaire et de ce point de vue là
c'est quand même quelque chose d'ABS
c'est exceptionnel quand on avait il
racontait les coulisses d'interview avec
Nasser avec sa date avec avec Gorbatchov
avec Poutine avec Mandela c'était
absolument exceptionnel de se dire on on
a l'histoire en réel avec lui oui c'est
une sorte d'histoire politique aussi
Jean-Pierre
la métaphore théâtrale il avait le génie
du narratif notamment pour raconter
l'envers du décor où il se mettait
lui-même en scène face à des gens qui
étaient c'était pas dit comme ça mais
c'est ce que ça voulait dire aussi
important que lui non mais il avait ce
génie et moi ce qui m'a toujours frappé
parce qu'on est le fruit de son enfant
c'est quand il perd son père qui fait
une prière dans la dans cette synagogue
à Oran je crois en fait il fait la
promesse que son père sera fier de lui
voyez et je pense que ils connaissent
son nom et en fait il court toujours je
pense
je peux pas faire de la psychologie à
Katsu inconsciemment ou inconsciemment
derrière c'est le volonté de penser à
son père qui est mort à ce moment-là et
pour que ce nom celui de son père est
donc le sien soit connu et ça m'a alors
moi je suis pas psychologue je suis pas
mais ça m'a toujours frappé
se raconte au tout début de son livre de
mémoire les rives de la mémoire c'est le
jour de Yom Kippour son père a un
malaise mortel à la synagogue de
effectivement d'Oran et c'est vrai que
ça explique aussi son parcours le qu'il
a eu commis quand même des moments très
difficiles philippender Osny ayant
quitté la télévision après le 10 mai 80
remis en selle par rentrer par la petite
porte une émission culturelle découverte
l'après-midi c'est à dire les tranches
les moins bonnes à l'époque de repas et
des parmi tes reins également il a
rebondi également après son départ de
France Télévisions pour une affaire qui
aujourd'hui ne ferait absolument pas la
moindre ligne des producteurs animateurs
il a toujours surmonté et je pense que
c'est lié aussi à ce parcours à cette
idée
cette résilience
théâtrale moi c'est plutôt sportif moi
j'avais parce que moi j'étais très
admiratif sa technique d'interview en
fait c'est plutôt un boxeur c'est un
puncheur c'est à dire que dans les
interviews il fallait que ça aille vite
parce qu'il aimait le chaos sur place il
emmenait en fait par ces questions hyper
incisives très courtes très courtes il
disait il faut les questions c'est dans
le coin du ring sont son interviewé
politique avec une gourmandise parfaite
il lui asséna du percute voyez et
c'était ça la technique d'interview
c'était pas
il emmenait dans le coin et le dernier
coup je vais être devait être
éblouissant sinon c'est ça je vous donne
la parole et après on va écouter ce que
disait Jean-Pierre Elkabbach de sa
technique d'interview justement les
idées oui on parlait de de
cet homme qui a quand même oui connu le
le pouvoir c'était une star bon et et on
a tous ressenti
peut-être une fragilité on peut appeler
ça le doute
le côté un ou parfois
à attendre quelque chose dans la
discussion à alors que il aurait pu être
sur son sur son
quant à soi et et
c'est souvent ça les exilés
son enfance c'est le fait que rien ne
lui était dû et que il y a toujours
cette fragilité qui ouvre les possibles
qui laissent la curiosité qui qui
comprend aussi la fragilité des autres
parce qu'on a rien voilà donc
c'est paradoxal que j'en parle comme ça
parce que pour moi génération moi
j'étais très engagée dans mon adolescent
et ma jeunesse et le 10 mai 81 et je
l'ai vécu en dansant avec le drapeau
dans les mains en place de la Bastille
et qui il a oui un carnet je pense de
façon un peu un peu bouc émissaire
peut-être cette cette fin de la droite
et de ceux qui ont incarné
effectivement ça a pas été toujours
facile notamment avec François mitter
mais juste
on va écouter ce que disait Jean-Pierre
Elkabbach c'était l'invité dans mon
regard il y a quelques semaines sur
notre antenne lors de cet entretien et
béca Fitoussi lui a demandé s'il était
un journaliste agressif on écoute sa
réponse un journaliste précis
provocateur quand il le faut quand on
interroge ou on rencontre des gens qui
parlent partout enfin en tout cas
réaliser c'est un peu votre marque de
fabrique
déstabiliser c'est chercher le plus
possible de vérité chez un être en face
il y en a qui n'aimait pas c'est
si compliqué sable politique qui ont du
mal à dire la vérité toute franchise
parce que
[Musique]
oui et souvent ils sont derrière le
masque et nous savons à force de les
connaître de les regarder de les lire il
y a quelque chose derrière
c'était ça aussi Jean-Pierre c'est un
peu l'obsession de de casser la façade
de casser les éléments de communication
et d'aller chercher les gens c'était la
16 vraiment quotidienne et hebdomadaire
parce que à cette époque j'étais les et
je peux présenter avec lui ce sont
autorité le grand rendez-vous et
effectivement l'obsession c'était
démaquillée le réel faire tomber le
masque et l'obsession de la première
question on passait des heures sur la
première question parfois on peut
commencer à préparer cette émission
dans le milieu de la semaine donc dès le
mercredi
puis après en fonction de l'actualité ça
pouvait changer on s'est retrouvé des
samedis soirs à minuit à chercher
l'invité pour le lendemain parce que
c'était ça aussi
c'était les principes journalistes à
l'ancienne être plus rapide être seul
ça c'était effectivement des principes
qui qu'on a vu petit à petit évoluer
parfois même disparaître parce que
aujourd'hui c'est voilà c'est
l'information de masse et c'était aussi
la possibilité de d'avoir un dialogue un
commerce journalistique avec des
responsables politiques qui n'étaient
pas encore prises en main par les
communicants donc effectivement il y
avait la possibilité d'aller débusquer
la parole réelle derrière le discours de
bon aloi que tout le monde doit avoir
c'est normal et il le dit pas seulement
les politiques les scientifiques les
écrivains les sportifs tout le monde à
son propre discours c'est normal et lui
le propos était de dire au fond comme on
a appris ce métier il faut aller
derrière les apparences et débusquer le
vrai discours derrière le discours
officiel et c'était la 16 permanente et
de ce point de vue là c'était absolument
passionnant de de travailler avec lui et
casser la langue de bois des politiques
d'avis de solide
oui oui en en jouant on en voit parce
que il aimait les petites phrases aussi
et ils savaient faire mousser
un dérapage ou
qui ne voulait pas qui qui voilà c'est
c'est donc il a il est quand même un
acteur d'une époque d'un journaliste
d'une époque d'un système entre
guillemets médiatique qui s'est installé
progressivement
avec avec un encouragement parce que
c'est la cinquième République il a
traversé entièrement aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs notre homme qui était pas de
mon bord politique et
j'ai une pensée pour lui ici Jacques
Valade qui a été au Sénat qui a aussi
traversé toute cette époque et qui était
le président de la commission culture
quand je suis arrivé ici et qui calmer
ses troupes parce que pareil il avait
une bienveillance avec moi qui était je
suis arrivé ici j'étais le jeune loup
qui faisait peur à la droite je ne sais
pas pourquoi enfin il essayait de me
cataloguer comme comme l'affreux qui va
tout casser et lui tranquille
avec cette bienveillance un peu comme
elle Kaba je pouvais l'avoir et et il a
disparu aussi je croyais et
qu'on soit ici chaîne qui dont il a été
le premier président c'est très
important d'en parler parce que c'est le
destin de Public Sénat aurait pu ne pas
être celui-là
moi de l'extérieur et même au début
Public Sénat on disait à quoi ça sert
franchement à la rigueur faire une
chaîne parlementaire en général bon ça
va être un truc d'initié il y aura
jamais de d'imat et tout et le fait que
il est voulu très vite j'ai vu moi j'ai
été invité aux émissions de Slade qui
essayer de toucher à tout l'émission du
soir ça te plaît
comme on dit à l'époque maintenant ça
doit se bousculer mais ça montre le
chemin c'est-à-dire que le fait de
vouloir faire associer Sénat aux mots
publics c'est-à-dire en faire l'affaire
d'un grand nombre et de devenir une
référence du débat politique un peu
exigeant et d'une chaîne exigeante
vraiment lui doit beaucoup là-dessus et
avec Public Sénat il a aussi voulu
rapprocher les élus les élus des
citoyens c'était ça aussi
de de ce média et citoyen mais il y
avait aussi effectivement la marque de
sa passion parce que il aurait pris
n'importe quel journal local il en
aurait fait ou il aurait voulu en faire
un grand quotidien international il
avait effectivement frappait les esprits
en République il avait fait en sorte de
d'aller diffuser en direct pour la
première fois les conventions démocrates
dans les élections américaines c'était
la première fois qu'on voyait en France
au fond des meetings et des discours
retransmis en direct dans leur
intégralité et de ce point-là il croyait
à sa puissance de cette de ce média de
ses discours là et de ce spectacle
politique effectivement parce qu'il
fallait toujours rapprocher et éviter
l'abstention éviter les extrêmes éviter
la désagration de de la politique quand
il a positionné Public Sénat sur sur la
primaire socialiste de 2006 qui était je
trouve
c'est le moment grand public parce que
c'était exclu donc tout le monde était
seul à le faire et voilà
c'est c'était voilà il aimait faire des
coups il était dans quelque chose qui
était toujours oui de de vouloir c'est
un homme de c'était un homme de média il
avait compris ce que c'est que percer le
mur du son et comment le faire et avant
même les chaînes d'infos Eric crevettes
vous qui avez travaillé sur une chaîne
d'info Jean-Pierre Elkabbach il a il a
fait ses grands directs bien avant les
sorts de ces chaînes d'infos après c'est
devenu plus banal oui enfin c'est devenu
plus banal il a il a obligé je pense un
centre de de dirigeants de médias de
chaîne info dont je faisais partie à
l'époque à se gratter la tête pour être
pour essayer de levancer pour essayer de
voir le meilleur coup que lui je me
souviens pendant la la campagne
présidentielle qui avait opposé François
Hollande à Nicolas Sarkozy j'avais créé
un concept où je en fait c'était en
regardant un jour Fox News bon hein
personne n'est parfait et j'avais vu
Sara Pauline ancienne candidat de
républicaine qui était devenue
chroniqueuse et je m'étais dit mais
c'est bien sûr et j'avais décidé de
mettre à l'antenne deux anciens Premiers
ministres à droite un de gauche
l'insoutenant la campagne de Sarko
l'autre celle de Hollande et c'est comme
ça que j'avais fait parole de premier ou
Jospin qui avait pourtant dit qu'il ne
ferait plus de politique était revenu
pendant une année entière en alternance
avec Jean-Pierre Raffarin pour commenter
sur trois minutes quatre minutes tous
les jours et
j'avais croisé Jean-Pierre j'ai plus il
m'avait dit bien joué bien joué alors on
était une chaîne payante donc c'est pas
très visible mais les médias on est
beaucoup parlé voilà et en fait oui
c'était un homme de cours et quand vous
êtes un journaliste un peu alors je sais
pas si c'est à l'ancienne mais enfin qui
qui a le nez politique qui essaie de
monter des choses en fait oui il a été
l'un des premiers à faire des coups en
fait dans ce qu'on appelle des coûts
dans votre métier ça a l'air des trucs
que les autres n'ont pas si possible le
premier si possible avec un contenu
original voilà il y avait une scène
émulation c'est à dire que vous dirigez
à LCI vous vous regardiez quand même
j'étais plus un repère si vous voulez
que compétiteur pour moi enfin oui
forcément mais mais le fait qu'il fasse
des coups ça vous poussait vous aussi à
réfléchir autrement parler des missions
politiques moi pendant des années et des
années
j'étais au Grand Jury RTL LCI Le Figaro
ou le monde le soir mais parfois il dû
arriver après l'émission de fine un
petit coup de téléphone disons
pas posé cette question là j'aurais pas
posé cette question là au début bon je
connais pas comme toi le dossier
économique mais j'aurais pas posé cette
question là j'aurais plutôt merci
Jean-Pierre comme ça comment c'est le
grand rendez-vous il m'a dit un truc
qu'on parle du Grand Jury et donc debout
en disant on va les avoir sauf que ils
sont sur la France c'est la France dans
l'Europe dans le monde et c'est ça aussi
c'était aussi un témoin de son époque
qui passait les frontières en permanence
Frédéric après je vous donne la parole
qui est très intéressant du fait de
cette passion du fait de ces de cette
longévité il a comment dire il a réussi
à s'adapter à tous les changements de
format du monde médiatique car sur table
c'est des années 70 on se souvient de la
fameuse intervention avec François
Mitterrand le 16 mars 80 ou à la fin de
l'émission alors qu'elle générique de
fin il pose la question sur l'abolition
de la peine de mort les socialistes
autour de François Mitterrand lui tombe
dessus sur le fait vous l'avez vous
l'avez piégé ben non finalement François
mitterrandit que il avait bien fait de
poser cette question là mais casse sur
table la Suisse était leur de vérité il
avait changé il était plus sur cette sur
ce format-là il allait sur les chaînes
info il est allé sur des formats qui
étaient pas des formats politiques je
parlais de découverte tout à l'heure il
y avait une émission également sur
France 3 je me souviens d'une algarade
très tendue avec Tapie mais il était
resté extrêmement calme et c'est vrai
que c'était aussi l'idée et vous parlez
de Michael de cette innovation de sortir
du cadre franco-français ça date avec
une question et également très très
émouvante sur pensez-vous à votre
possible assassinat tous les jours et au
moment de la mort de sa date puisque ça
date répondait en anglais c'est passé
sur toutes les chaînes du monde que le
fait que ça date avait pressenti sa
disparition et c'est vrai que c'était
sortir de l'interview politique
à la Bastille donc c'est quelqu'un qui
rebondit ses permanence et de ce point
de vue là effectivement c'était une
manière pour lui traverser toute
l'époque compliqués peut-être David
d'Assouline avec François Mitterrand
notamment il a été viré Jean-Pierre
Elkabbach quelques mois après l'arrivée
de mitter emploi et c'est lui finalement
qui réalise la dernière interview de
François Mitterrand oui bah c'est c'est
le paradoxe qui vient d'être soulevé je
je pense qu'il a été beaucoup bouc
émissaire pourquoi parce que la télé
c'était assez verticale et que ça
représentait quand même le pouvoir
en place et que comme il avait un rôle
qui devait être prêt que il était
déstabilisant et que donc forcément
la on se souvient de ce de Georges
Marchais qui dit taisez-vous un cabane
il n'a jamais dit taisez-vous c'est
Thierry Le Luron qui avait été tellement
il y a beaucoup de paradoxes parce qu'il
y a celui-là il y a aussi celui
voilà je je peux le dire quand même avec
du recul c'est que dans cette longévité
qu'on loue tous parce que il a pu
traverser toutes ses époques il y a
aussi un agacement légitime de la part
de beaucoup parce que on disait mais
c'est quand qu'il laisse la place mais
peut-être plus les hommes politiques de
gauche que droite
un journaliste de droite il y en avait
pas beaucoup dans sa génération qui
incarnait et et et qui avait pas la
droite que vous aimez mais enfin c'est
pas grave
si vous voulez bon enfin bon c'est pas
le sujet ce matin non mais c'est
peut-être oui une partie une classe
politique
il n'aimait pas beaucoup les idées qu'on
peut qu'on peut aujourd'hui voir se
répandre sur certains médias européens
etc n'aimez pas ces idées là parce qu'il
était pour la fraternité mais je je je
voulais vous dire que dans ce paradox
c'était pas chez les politiques il a
gassait dans sa longévité c'était aussi
dans le milieu même en disant c'est
quand qu'il laisse la place pourquoi
comme comme pour les politiques quand il
garde tout le temps la place on met le
paradoxe c'est que si il a pu avoir
cette longévité dans un monde qui s'est
bouleversé complètement c'est à dire que
il incarnait pas le pépère qui fait
l'interview comme il y a 50 ans c'est ça
donc c'est pour ça aussi qu'il a pu
durer c'est un milieu ça a été décrit
dont les formats le type de médias tout
ça a été tellement bouleversé les
technologies que s'il a pu durer c'est
qu'il avait cet appétit quand même
d'être tout le temps dans aussi
l'innovation et justement on va voir les
réactions du monde politique elles ont
été énormément de pierres de réaction
avec ce communiqué notamment de l'Elysée
ce matin Emmanuel Macron qui salue un
monstre sacré du journaliste français
une mort qui intervient à la veille du
65e anniversaire de notre cinquième
République lui qui était toujours là
pour en raconter les et en interroger
les acteurs réactions également on en
parlait tout à l'heure de Nicolas
Sarkozy qui a été l'un des premiers à
dégainer tristesse de voir partir un
grand du journaliste passionné de
politique boulimique d'informations
également de François Hollande une page
de notre histoire politique et
médiatique se tourne c'était une voix
que nulle ne pouvait faire taire si je
garde de lui cette insatiable curiosité
qui jusqu'au bout l'animait et cette
soif inaltérable de comprendre et de
savoir gérer à l'archet a également
réagi pendant plus de 50 ans il a marqué
l'histoire de la radio et de la
télévision de son sens politique et de
son grand professionnelalisme et puis du
côté de l'Assemblée nationale il y a
LeBron pivée écrit la chose suivante
Jean-Pierre Elkabbach fine l'âme de
l’interview politique restera pour les
Français une voix un ton une plume ça
sagacité suscitait intérêt et passion
pour la chose publique
d'autres clins d'oeil oui un clin d'oeil
d'une de ses anciennes victimes comment
mieux entrer en dans une interview
politique de cette façon là on va revoir
cette séquence et puis on verra la
réaction de sa victime ensuite
quelle couleur vous préférez pour le mur
le mur quel mur
comment qu'elle mur le mur sur lequel
votre réforme territoire va se fracasser
d'abord elle ne va pas se fracasser je
pense qu'on peut réussir cette réforme
même si les résistances sont nombreuses
les Français attendent cette réforme qui
n'est pas rancunier l'ancien ministre
rend hommage à son bourreau ce matin
cher Jean-Pierre alkabbache ne sont
jamais de quelle couleur était le mieux
grande tristesse après la disparition de
cette légende du journaliste du
journaliste politique voilà c'est écrit
l'ancien sénateur de l'Isère autre
réaction d'un sénateur en fonction cette
fois-ci le patron du groupe lèvres Bruno
retaillod hommage à Jean-Pierre
Elkabbach l'un des interviews les plus
talentueux les plus exigeants de sa
génération le journalisme et la
politique perd un esprit brillant et
cultivé côté socialiste Patrick Kanner
président du groupe PS écrit la chose
suivante être interviewé par Jean-Pierre
Elkabbach a toujours été une épreuve
face à ce redoutable contradicteur les
éléments de langage étaient vins et
immédiatement balayé sa poigne ne
supportait aucun faux semblant je suis
triste de sa disparition voilà hommage
on imagine l'anime ce matin Michael
daron
que tout le monde a
[Musique]
à TF1 il commençait un peu à se poser la
question il restait toujours premier
mais il se posait la question parce que
ça commençait vraiment à grignoter et
ensuite il a été justement débarqué
avant de se quitter Steve on regarde
parce que il y a quand même dans la
presse régionale ce matin des choses sur
sa formation
qui ont été très réactives le
Républicain Lorrain écrit qu'une grande
voie du journalisme c'est tue le
Parisien fait aussi c'est une avec une
grande photo de cette figure d'Europe 1
et ancien patron de France Télé de
Public Sénat l'Est Républicain revient
sur son incroyable carrière en 1970
critiqué souvent viré mais infatigable
et c'est souvent remis en selle une
belle leçon pour les plus jeunes
journalistes lisait son portrait dans
l'Est Républicain ce matin merci Steve
merci à tous les quatre merci d'être
venu pour ce club spécial évidemment
hommage à Jean-Pierre Elkabbach on pense
à sa famille on pense à ceux qui ont
travaillé avec lui merci beaucoup de
nous avoir suivis très bonne journée on
se retrouve demain
[Musique]